[Musica]
buon pomeriggio
vorrei chiedervi per un momento di
venire con me nello spazio vorrei
chiedervi di diventare per un attimo
astronauti
chiudete gli occhi tenetevi chiusi e
sempre ad occhi chiusi
non succede nulla fa quindi tenete gli
occhi chiusi guardatevi intorno e
cercate di percepire le sensazioni che
lo spazio che sta dando ora tornate coi
piedi per terra
alcuni di voi soprattutto se avete visto
magari il primo uomo avranno pensato di
essere sulla luna magari con neil
armstrong oppure avranno pensato di
essere sulla stazione spaziale con
samantha cristoforetti o magari anche
paolo nespoli o uscire in una piccola
passeggiata spaziale con luca parmitano
oppure magari con curiosity su marte o
anche piantando patate con matteo o
magari avete pensato di essere sulla
sonda rosetta e avvicinarvi a quella
natura che la cometa 67p non so quanti
di voi però abbiano sentito la
leggerezza dell'amico gravità o abbiano
percepito la pesantezza e la pressione
di uno scafandro sul vostro corpo
questo il problema che abbiamo noi
istruttori di astronauti che dobbiamo
insegnare a fare cose in un ambiente nel
quale non siamo mai stati lo spazio
quindi quindi lo spazio bisogna
simularlo ho bisogno di crearlo oppure
bisogna andare a ricercare nella sola
terra degli ambienti che sono ambienti
analoghi terrestri e questi ambienti
devono simulare dipende possono simulare
la superficie di un pianeta come in
questo caso piuttosto l'interno che
all'interno di una stazione spaziale o
piuttosto che
all'esterno della stazione spaziale per
una camminata spaziale o anche
eventualmente l'interno di una grotta un
tubo di lava sulla luna quindi molti
analoghi diversi e in questi analoghi
bisogna cercare di entrare perché nel
2004 ho avuto l'esperienza di provare lo
scafandro della nasa alla news buoni
anzi facility della nasa
ho provato lo scafandro questo cup
andrebbero paese a 100 kg quindi avendo
100 chili sulle spalle non si può
muoversi con lo scafandro è necessario
entrare in acqua quindi verrete presi
con una gru che vi calerà all'interno
della piscina una volta che siete
all'interno due sub di sicurezza vi
porteranno a un corrimano che ha
attaccato a un modulo della stazione
spaziale che sta all'interno della
piscina e poi dovete muovervi
bella domanda adesso muoversi da soli
all'interno gli istruttori della nasa vi
diranno non litigare con uno scafandro
io ci ho litigato per quattro ore
perché effettivamente muoversi
all'interno di qualcosa non è facile uno
scafandro è un veicolo spaziale in tutto
e per tutto li protegge dal vuoto vi
protegge dai micro meteoriti vi protegge
dalle radiazioni
vi offre comunicazioni vida dell'area da
respirare anche dei razzi per muovere
nel caso che vi per test e un pochino
nello spazio ma è pessimo e terribile
muoversi in questo scafandro quando sono
tornata da questa esperienza
stavo cercando di creare con un collega
in corso per far imparare ai futuri
astronauti europei come diventare degli
ottimi degli ottimi spacewalker e i
nostri istruttori che mi avevano portato
in questa esperienza mi avevano detto
che ciò non tre tipi di astronauti gli
astronauti che ci provano ma non
riescono riusciranno mai veramente a
muoversi bene in questo scafandro poi ci
sono quelli che col tempo riusciranno a
imparare
e poi ci sono quelli che sono dei
ballerini spaziali che si mettono
all'interno di uno scafandro come se ci
fossero nati dentro il mio obiettivo era
quello di insegnare ai futuri astronauti
europei a diventare di ballerini
spaziali quindi ho cominciato a pensare
quali sono le sensazioni che io ho
provato in questo ambiente estremo
perché molto estremo questo questo
scafandro per cercare di spiegare loro
come possono muoversi e sono stata
qualche ora in piscina con il mio
collega alla fine mi sono resa conto che
il modo in cui io avrei sarei riuscita
veramente a muovermi come mi muovevo
nello scafandro era quello di pensarmi
paralizzata cioè dal dal bacino in giù
non avere le gambe essere completamente
realizzata solo in questo modo sarei
riuscita a spostarmi usando le braccia
senza usare la torsione del corpo che
totalmente inutile non scafandro molto
origine un consumato russo mi ha detto
qualche tempo fa che un astronauta
ideale non è una nota senza gambe perché
le gambe sono totalmente inutile nello
spazio dipende da dove nello spazio
ovviamente ma dove in microgravità non
ti servono luca parmitano diceva una
presentazione che abbiamo fatto insieme
qualche qualche anno fa a padova che
sarebbe ottimo avere una coda prensile
perché ti permetterebbe di attaccati da
qualche parte e allo stesso tempo
continuare ad usare le braccia per far
cose perché tu alla fine devi fare cose
in realtà noi siamo adattati
all'ambiente nel quale viviamo che la
terra e la nostra culla questo è un
ambiente nel quale noi ci sentiamo a
nostro agio l'ambiente in cui ci siamo
evoluti un ambiente diverso come lo
spazio richiede la capacità che noi
dobbiamo soffrire con la tecnologia
diventando a volte anche bionici a volte
addirittura pensando di cambiare quelle
che sono le capacità del nostro corpo
etico non si sa però ci permetterebbe di
adattarci a quell'ambiente qualunque
ambiente estremo che noi vogliamo
visitare sia gli oceani possono essere
delle grotte tubi di rava può essere il
ghiaccio una calotta glaciale può essere
anche un uno spazio ad esempio lo spazio
tipo marte dal una qualunque ambiente
estremo ci richiederà una protezione per
il nostro corpo quindi uno scafandro
qualunque una tuta dei caschi qualcosa
per comunicare quindi tecnologia ci
chiederà di avere dei rover come in
questo caso un robot sottomarino ci
chiederà di avere comunque delle
tecnologie che ci aiuteranno a soffrire
a quelle che sono le nostre mancanze le
nostre incompletezze in quell'ambiente
per poter raggiungere dei luoghi anche
che non sono accessibili quindi avremmo
bisogno di droni avremo bisogno di robot
che ci permettono di andare là dove noi
per le nostre limitazioni umani non
saremmo in grado di andare noi li
percepiamo la normalità come qualcosa di
particolare quando si parla di un
ambiente estremo la normalità per me e
ridefinita dell'adattamento all'ambiente
in cui siamo noi siamo perfettamente
adattati all'ambiente terrestre
se cambiamo i parametri di questo
ecosistema automaticamente diventiamo
dei disabili e dobbiamo a supplire a
queste disabilità cercando di usare
l'ingegno la tecnologia diventando anche
bionici imparando con molta umiltà tra
l'altro a muoverci un ambiente nel quale
noi non siamo assolutamente adattati a
vivere in questo caso le detenute up
luca parmitano una grotta in sicilia che
a 30 gradi con 100 per cento di umidità
molto difficile e la foto che avete
visto prima era un giovane che abbiamo
usato per esplorare un pozzo era a 40
gradi di umilità ma di di temperatura
con 100 per cento di umidità
dobbiamo in questi casi ridefinire
quella che è la nostra normalità ora vi
chiedo di nuovo di chiudere gli occhi
non succederà nulla quindi chiudeteli
stavolta però pensate di essere gli
astronauti
all'interno di uno scafandro sulla luna
e dover scendere all'interno di un tubo
di lava però stavolta sentite la
pesantezza di questo scafandro su di voi
sentite la difficoltà di muovere le mani
che sono dentro dei guanti molto spessi
e pressurizzati che non vi lasciano
afferrare la corda che dovete usare e
che dovete attaccare al vostro scafandro
il vostro cavallo è molto rigido voi
dovete muovervi dovete piegarvi dovete
riuscire a entrare in una zona che sarà
buia quindi avete bisogno della luce è
il vostro casco a un visore il viso
ricomincia appannarsi perché voi state
respirando molto forte
ora aprite gli occhi pensate per un
attimo alle persone che qui sulla terra
non sono adattate come voi a vivere una
vita normale perché hanno quelli che noi
chiamiamo disabilità persone che sono
diversamente abili
queste persone in realtà sono astronauti
sulla terra potrebbero essere dei
perfetti istruttori perché hanno capito
perfettamente come adattarsi vivere e
anche come sfruttare al massimo
l'ambiente estremo che la nostra terra
la tecnologia fa a diventare loro
bionici ci fa capire come effettivamente
possiamo con la tecnologia diventare di
superuomini per me loro sono i super
eroi del nostro tempo
[Applauso]